hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of the ftx road to miami uh
knockouts it is we ye versus levon
arenan and uh this is the second part of
the match first uh part of the match was
yesterday now levon uh one it was uh it
was a very tough fight the first three
games ended in a draw and then levon got
a win with the black piece in the final
game
i believe it was a a
aragosan defense uh and
also yi did not have all that much luck
in the second game of the match where
again levon had the black pieces uh and
levon won the game with uh darago and
another ghost and he first went for the
gracos and then he went for the nimzo
indian defense uh but it was a pretty it
was completely equal and then i believe
we just blundered in the end game he
gave up a pawn and then the game was
completely lost so now we needs the
bonds back and this is his last chance
this is game four uh he absolutely must
win this uh in order to
uh uh
or rather this is game three he has to
win this and he has to win uh in in game
four in order to force uh tie breaks so
let's see how it went uh as it features
a most interesting move that has only
been played a handful of times already
on move three uh so we opens with uh
d4 we have knight to f6 by level one c
for e6 again saying i have uh i've had
uh very good success here like i said
playing the nimzo indian and the the
in the daragoza uh we have g4 by way
avoiding all of that and saying uh let's
let's play this and it's a move that um
on the on the absolute highest level has
been employed only by shakira mamidyarov
uh he employed it twice once against the
wei yi that's why we probably uh played
the played against levon uh and also uh
mamidarov tried it in an actual
classical game in the tata steel chess
tournament this year in january against
um andreas penco uh the game ended in a
draw so it's incredibly sharp and it uh
well basically asks black do you have
anything ready for this if you don't you
will probably uh not have a great time
playing especially in a rapid game where
you have to make quick moves so uh best
is as usual to just capture a bottle of
one uh doesn't have anything to do with
that he just plays bishop to b4 with
check and it is now uh already as of
move three that we have a completely new
game uh we have bishop to d2 blocking
bishop captures queen captures and now
d5 now levon is inviting g5 that's the
idea behind g4 because now he can play
knight to e4 and attack the the white
queen so here we have knight to c3
defending the e4 square and now d
captures on c4 we have g5 and knight to
d5 we have h for now uh and bishop to d7
so uh incredibly sharp uh but uh
if this was uh if this was actually good
everyone would play it but for a rapid
game as a surprise uh
i mean it it's definitely a valid
attempt uh so e4 grabbing the full
center uh attacking the knight knight
back to b6 and now knight to f3 uh we
have knights the c6 level on continuous
development and uh we have a castle's
queen side queen to e7
uh levon also wants the castle queen
side he's not uh uh
rushing to the king side to face those
marching pawns
so d5 already starting the attack you
don't want to capture
then you just allow y to open up the
position your king is still in the
center of the board so knight to b4 and
now queen to d4 putting pressure on the
on the g7 pawn so f6 by levon and now
pawn to e5 putting uh
a lot of pressure on that f6 pawn but
levon just castles queen side and this
is very interesting uh why would he
allow this capture well the thing is uh
levon has a a very nice trick in mind
it's not really a trick it's a defensive
idea because after all of the trades on
the f6 square queen f7 and now if
something like knights to g5 uh go going
after the queen you can play a queen to
g6 you just threaten checkmate you've
stopped the attack and white doesn't
really have
all that much uh to do here and of
course if you go knight here then you
can capture the f6 pawn and it's
perfectly safe for black nothing
happening here so instead we have pawn
to d6 uh going straight for the black
king and now c captures on d6 with e
captures on d6 and queen to f7 uh queen
to c5 with check it seems that levon is
getting checkmated but not really he has
to go back with the knight otherwise he
could also blunder the knight so knights
to c6 and now pawn to a4 just going
after the black king regardless of where
he is king to b8 and now pawn to a5 we
have knights the d5 and now bishop
captures and c4 so uh
we is attacking here and he is uh
putting a lot of pressure on the black
king but he's also exposing his own king
a bit much so knight captures and see
three b captures into rook to c8 now the
one goes for the counter attack bishop
to b3 and now queen to h5 he has to
bring the queen into the game somehow
this comes with tempo
so of course the knight has to be
defended we have uh rook to d3 also
knights the d4 is very nice just putting
more pressure on the
uh black queen side but rook the d3 is
played here and now levon strikes in the
center with e5 and this is now very
dangerous e4 is coming
so you you have to be ready for that we
have knight to d2 and now knight to d4
beautiful discovery uh although you can
uh
defend its uh
really hard position to play as the way
he absolutely must win this in order to
uh to equalize the the match and then
try and win game four
uh so queen to b4 uh getting the queen
out of harm's way and now uh now comes
the move that uh well if you don't find
it you're not going to be winning the
game with white but if you find it then
well white is very very
uh limited in the choice of moves so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the only good move for lavon
to push for a win uh while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh sneaky attack and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course queen to e2 now we're attacking
the rook we're attacking the f2 pawn and
the white is uh it seems is is without a
move uh and uh
well
you could try something like a6 you
could go after the the uh b7 pawn but
just b6 and nothing is really happening
here uh so bishop to d5 was played
trying to checkmate levon's king this
way but here levon just played bishop to
c6 and he was in this position on move
26 that uh
way he resigned the game and a brilliant
brilliant victory for levon not just in
the game but also in the match and
interestingly the match lasted for seven
games uh eight uh uh uh
again eighth game was uh not necessary
as uh even if uh uh even if uh he wins
uh it will not be enough to take a chop
to live on uh but interestingly the only
games that uh ended uh with uh with a
decisive result
that weren't a draw uh were all games
where levon won with the black pieces so
that's really really incredible and it's
something that um
i've mentioned quite a few times in
in the uh uh
past couple of games that we've analyzed
uh that uh
there are just uh a lot more wins with
the black piece i don't know why this is
it's probably because uh
well usually you know in the old days
you knew if you had white you had the
advantage but nowadays uh people are
just so well prepared with black they
they just have brilliant brilliant
defensive resources they have you know
everything ready for everything you
can't really surprise them uh so i guess
that might be uh one of the reasons if
you guys have any other ideas uh you
know feel free to share in the comments
uh so yeah i hear you resign you could
try and find it out for example bishop
captures rook characters but it's very
very hard to find a move for white your
rook is hanging i mean you could play
something like rook to h3 uh but now uh
after rook to d8 there really isn't a
good move for white you're we're going
to capture this pawn here and that's
just it uh but you could maybe continue
uh if
for example you want to try and give
levon a chance to maybe blunder if he
plays rook to c8 seems like a good idea
putting more pressure on that c3 pawn
now d7 will win the game for white so
it's possible but the way he was very
low on time he had some 30 seconds on
the clock level maybe like seven and a
half minutes so he didn't want to uh try
anything weird here or let's see who
wrote the d8 queen e7 and now you are
already uh you know uh fighting for for
your life here knight to e6 we defend
the rook rook the rook the d6 attacks
the knight and here
black would most likely resign uh but
yeah after bishop to c6 we said all
right i've had enough um i'm disgusted
with with the finals uh
and uh he decided to resign here uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys uh
enjoyed it uh very nicely done by lavone
really uh another master of the mystic
arts uh you know just a brilliant
brilliant positional player
and especially if you try such a crazy
idea against a player like levon you can
see that you will not have a have a
great time because he can just easily
neutralize all the threats and just
enjoy a better position
so yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it uh if you have any other uh
uh games that we've missed that were
really interesting feel free to suggest
them i will go over them uh but uh uh
yeah we're continuing uh to check up on
some other suggestions i've received a
lot of uh suggestions regarding uh
glucage
passing 2700
barrier so we're going to cover a game
of his as well uh so stay tuned for that
uh but yeah i really hope you enjoyed it
uh always you know be careful uh uh of
moves like g4 you have to be ready for
them even though they are not the the
strongest of moves but you know yeah if
uh a player like way you can play it
against levon uh you will most likely
encounter it playing online uh so yeah
once again uh i hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank uh francis sarah
babur nugmanov margo pink alessandro
ligobello uh and uh paul hindermoon uh
hinnemund for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day
you